i really want to play this game with you
back-to-school staff stories there's a
guy on our staff i was shocked by this
one of the guys we work with every day
masturbated in his spanish class he was
never caught and he would complete in
his pants he'd come in his pants during
space in the classroom if you're playing
at home this involves bubba booy gary
jason
richard
mike perlman
steve nowicki
sal
chris wilding those are the list of
people from our staff
and you have to guess
immediately when you say something like
masturbating in public
[Applause]
i have to think sal but then you throw
in spanish class was sal allowed in a
classroom where they taught a language i
think so yeah i think style probably was
in a class where
she had to take all remedial studies i
don't think they you know like he was
getting ready for boces spanish was a
requirement for him to graduate right
one of these people used to masturbate
he masturbated in class to full
completion and he's a smart guy he was
never caught and he completed in his
pants
gonna say
jason
wow
you are right
damn it
i've been harder
that's something style would do addy you
know spanish class was the only thing
that threw it off we knew sal didn't eat
that he loved creep me you swab
robin
uh yeah it was once by the way
did you hear that i said how'd you pull
that off thank you
uh it was once it was not multiple times
i was absolutely disgusted with myself
and crossed out but
yeah i was sitting in the back of this
class i had just moved i didn't know
anybody i was just i don't i don't i
don't remember what i was thinking about
i had a boner and then just kind of just
flicking it and then i don't know
somehow my hand ended up under my pants
and then i'm like oh i think i could get
away with this like i just remembered
that was the thought and then i did and
then it was over and uh that was did you
have a big stain in your pants yeah no i
had a run i had to wait to go to the
bathroom class i mean the whole thing
was humiliating but i was so ignored in
high school especially those years and i
probably could have walked down the hall
with a big giant [ __ ] coming down my
pants and nobody would have even noticed
yeah you know it's weird i was kind of
invisible too i wasted valuable years of
not jerking off in school because i
don't think anyone would i mean it's a
terrible thing to jerk off in class and
realize nobody cares that you're there
nobody notices a friend of mine jerked
off an art class he thought nobody
noticed but everybody could tell just
the look on his face and like the
emotion that he's doing you got to learn
i keep a straight face when i jerk off
i came three times during the show today
see if you can find what place it was
one of these guys sprayed a substitute
teacher with a fire extinguisher
frayed a substitute teacher with a fire
extinguisher that's a crime that's some
gangster [ __ ]
yeah
mike
no it's steve nowicki steve what's up
with that steve
it's the stupidest thing i've probably
ever done in my life i didn't think
anything would spray out of it because
they usually i thought they had a safety
pin
in it and i didn't think it would spray
but it was right before we were about to
walk out at graduation and i don't know
i i got like carried away i'm like we're
about to graduate and you can't really
do crazy [ __ ] in the real world after
this and you got to have fun in high
school while you can and i wasn't really
going to spray it and then it sprayed
and it shot all over the substitute
teacher wow and then i spent the whole
graduation ceremony sitting there
thinking i was going to get arrested
like in front of all the parents and all
the students i thought they were going
to come in and just take me away in
handcuffs and i thought i'm not gonna
graduate one of these animals sitting
here was just suspended from school for
decorating the inside
of his school locker with extremely
graphic pictures of naked women
all right well then i gotta say that's
val
at sal you're right very good
robin you know you're creeps man
[Music]
[Laughter]
you didn't know not to do that
i figured howard if it was in the inside
of my locker no one would see it when
they say graphic like what was in your
locker oh glued in there
not like playboy centerfolds these were
like uh those off magazines like
plumpers and cherry
where the girls would have their heads
pinned behind their legs you know and
their vagina lips were stretched out
like silly putty
real graphic geez
probably like grannies too
yeah like someone's like were bent over
with the ass cheeks spread open so you
see this
i love those pictures so
it was your interest you were just
putting in your locker your interests i
had to leave class because i forgot my
english book and there's always a school
monitor in the hallways usually another
teacher is off for that period
and i opened the uh door the locker door
and all of a sudden i heard stop right
there
and she walked over i was like holy [ __ ]
and i reached for the pictures on the
locker and she stops my hand she goes
don't rip them off take them off by the
corners nice and slow
peel them off she folded them up she
gave them to my school principal he
checked them out he folded them up and
he emailed them to my house and i was
suspended for a day sal never learned
his lesson because remember sal used to
take porno magazines out of glom and
he'd hide him inside a newspaper and go
to the bathroom at work you used to go
across the street to jerk off too oh
yeah i used to go to mcdonald's
mcdonald's
i get the napkins then i go in do you
get hot when you pass a mcdonald's when
you see those arches
oh it brings back the memories robin rob
and i remember the exact mcdonald's on
57th street where sal used to do that
every time i would go buy it i'm like
that's where it's all jerked off all
right here's another one for you oh my
god
this guy's so nutty he threw his desk
his chair and then himself out a second
story classroom window
[Music]
well that's gotta be mike then that's
what i'm saying
it's mike
[ __ ] nut job i won't be wrong twice
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you what do
you mean what happened i did it a few
times at first like you know at first i
did just kind of
i did just to make the class laugh or
whatever
and then um then i would just start
doing it just to ditch class you go in
you get your attendance taken then you
just i would just go right out the
window
mike yeah you're in
yeah
you're in a classroom you pick up your
chair and you throw it out the window
and it's a second story window it could
have landed on someone's head but you
didn't i launched i made sure nobody was
laughing yeah i didn't care
you know the class is watching
everyone's laughing the teacher doesn't
know anything you know what i'll take it
to the next level and i just went right
out after that second floor there's
concrete down there and i mean are you
do you land on your feet or do you like
drop and roll
i landed on my head it was like wood
chips i think at the bottom
i ate some wood chips i'm telling you
everybody i hire here pretty much has
this kind of background
i i don't really go after that harvard
lampoon crowd like letterman did or
conan certainly they intimidate me those
guys i'm you know i'm just i'm more
comfortable with guys who throw
themselves out the window and jerk off
in spanish
i got a national community here what did
you do um yeah i jerked off in my pants
and in front of my class uh oh okay tell
me more about you my top guy i lit my
school on fire
here's a 20-year career thank you
i'm like that's pretty funny
you're a funny guy
howard literally when you hired me i was
sleeping on the floor of my storage unit
and cockroaches used to wake me up
because they crawl over my face
you're hired that's right i'd say to
robin there's a guy i think is going to
be loyal to me
i can't imagine anyone else hiring him
hey it's 17 years so far this guy on our
staff was constantly late to school so
he forged letters from his mom to excuse
his tardiness
it ended when he was called down to the
school office where his mom sat with
over 25 of his forged letters
who's that
chris
nah it's gary gary delaby gary did that
damn he's a liar i'm the first i'm the
first one here who hasn't jerked off at
school
just a fraudster yeah but you know i
don't mind the other stories the yours
is the most disturbing
you know a guy wants to throw himself
out the window that's an entertainer
there's a guy who's got show business in
his blood he's looking at the group and
going what can i do to make these people
get through their drudgery
but you
you're lying i mean you're forging
you're committing forgiveness
gary is the guy who draws within the
lines that's crazy to me that you did
that
another time in my life robin when uh
here's the thing my dad used to leave
for work first thing in the morning i
never even saw him you know my dad was
not very involved in day-to-day
operations i think he spent the bulk of
his time at work trying to figure out
how to fake his own death so it was me
and my mom
and she didn't get up she never got up
right so i would always sleep through
the alarm i don't mean in a bad way but
i think my mom was kind of medicated so
i would ask her to um
nothing bad about that no and then at
one point
robin i kid you not at one point i was
putting the pen in her hand and moving
it while she was in bed because she was
so adamant
so then i think i just figured well she
was almost i was moving her hands i was
practically doing it anyway let me ask
you something you mean you mean you
would you would write a note and you
said you need to sign this and then she
was so whacked out on her meds that you
would just like put a pen in her hand
and move her hand for her i did that
technically she was still signing it
that's amazing
this pervert had sex in the school
bathroom who do you think that is
well then it's got to be chris yeah of
course
that doesn't surprise what some dude
blew you in the bathroom i blew the dude
were you openly gay in high school or
were you yeah
i mean i probably was giving off vibes
and and so with this guy
but no one was really out so it was hard
to sort of meet up and figure out if you
could be with somebody i remember one
day he kind of like pinned me up against
my locker and said like you know we're
going to we're going to be together
we're going to have fun
and i really okay well cool because that
just made things easier i broke the ice
i said great yeah
weeks later we were at some party and he
blew me it's the first time i'd ever
been blown
and he's blowing me and i'm like this is
like you know a very weird sensation but
i'm digging it halfway through it he
just gets up and leaves and i didn't
know why because i'll be back okay so
i'm sitting there
we're in a basement right so i feel like
the cool air sort of hitting my my [ __ ]
and i'm like wow this is like a weird
sensation but it starts getting cooler
and cooler like almost like a menthol
type situation so i pull my foreskin
back
he left his chewed up
gum inside my foreskin
like smeared to the head of my [ __ ]
you know that guy's name because i want
to hire him for the show
you're telling me the first [ __ ] you
got the guy left his gum in your
foreskin yeah and took off here's
richard's thing yeah what did richard do
he brought two six-foot snakes to school
and let them loose in the hallway right
before class let out
that seems like something written
finally something funny and not criminal
thanks robin something lovely it was
hilarious
a bunch of weirdos but i love all you
[Music]
you